one of the most popular ways to make a
quick buck in Hollywood is to rip off a
hit and that practice has a long sketchy
history in the film industry around the
world after the massive success of
1977's Star Wars it seemed like
everybody got caught in the space craze
and the result was an entire sub-genre
of Mach busters that obviously wanted to
be in a galaxy far far away but never
quite got there here are a few of the
strangest attempts to rip off Star Wars
message from space everybody in the
world wanted to make a Star Wars
knockoff in 1978 and Japan's legendary
to--a company was no exception message
from space stole its look and
characterizations from Star Wars and
mixed it with manga and anime -
generally bizarre results the most
striking thing about message from space
is that despite only having half the
budget of a new hope the special effects
are surprisingly competent well they
suffer maybe this
[Music]
still it pretty much owes its life to
George Lucas most obviously lifted from
Star Wars is a princess on the run
seeking help from wide-eyed space
jockeys accompanied by a funny robot on
the other hand message from space also
had its own dramatic Yoda death scene
way before Star Wars ever did aside from
that message from space feels like the
movie a person might make if they'd
heard a vague description of Star Wars
but hadn't actually seen it a comedian
and drag plays an evil Empress and
instead of the force there are space
walnuts that fly around choosing people
to do something still beats
midi-chlorians though star crash when
most normal well-adjusted humans watch
Star Wars they didn't come away thinking
that movie was pretty great but it
needed more weird swimsuits as it turned
out Italian director Luigi Cozzi
wasn't a normal person he quickly
whipped up the movie star crash by 1979
a shameless Star Wars ripoff that was
basically an excuse to get nearly naked
women on camera star crash tells the
story of a war between a Galactic Empire
and the evil count South Arm who has a
super weapon that the heroes have to
blow up characters use light sabers and
fight evil robotic minions but once
those similarities are out of the way
star crash reaches a level of incredible
ridiculousness that George Lucas could
only touch in fever dreams we just
survived an attack of the most powerful
weapon in the entire galaxy
we have heroine Stella star spends most
of the movie in a bikini gets captured
by a tribe of scantily clad Amazons is
chased around by a giant robot woman
[Music]
gets frozen and helps the Empire win
their giant space battle Plus as a bonus
a young and beautiful David Hasselhoff
Luigi Cozzi maintains that he came up
with the script before Star Wars came
out though so who knows maybe George
Lucas was the one making the rip-off
Cosi definitely be them when it came to
making one of the heroes the bad guys
son Turkish Star Wars also known as
words we can't hope to pronounce this
movie is unique among other ripoffs
because it literally lifts footage
straight from a new hope and plops it
into the movie the Death Star the
Millennium Falcon x-wings Tie Fighters
and the Mos Eisley cantina all of these
things can be found in Turkish Star Wars
and that isn't even the craziest thing
about the movie the film starts with two
pilots maratton Ali crashing on a desert
planet during a space battle past that
there really isn't any hope of following
the plot Ali accidentally summons a
skeleton army by whistling there's a
planetary shield made of human brain
molecules that looks suspiciously like
the Death Star Murat karate chops
monsters in half somewhere along the way
a story happens
when the movie came out 20th Century Fox
was evidently so stumped by it that they
didn't even try to sue even today
Disney owned Lucasfilm still hasn't
taken action it's so bad they don't even
view it as a threat but Star Wars
probably would have been even cooler at
Luke rip the head off of wampa the shape
of things to come
in 1979 Canadian director George McGowan
set out to make his own Star Wars
knockoff buying the rights to HG Welles
1933 novel the shape of things to come
since Canada isn't really known as a
science fiction hotspot it's easy to
guess how things turned out
the film was already off to a rough
start because HG Wells book is actually
a speculative novel about the future of
the world from 1933 to 2106 and it
features a distinct lack of robots
literally none of the things in the
novel happened in the movie Macallan
just shamelessly bought the rights just
so he could use a title people might
know for his movie and like most movies
of the era the shape of things to come
had a pretty low budget look plot wise
it's pretty much just Star Wars just set
on Earth's moon after a robot war
there's a bad guy who has a massive
fortress and a resistance movement
trying to stop him but Cowen thought if
he made the bad guy use robot drones as
his minions nobody would know it was a
shameless ripoff he was wrong you're the
hunter from the future at first you're
doesn't look much like a Star Wars
ripoff it starts out as a barbarian
sword and loincloth features set to the
sweet sounds of 80s hair metal we got a
guy hunting dinosaurs meeting magical
people and seducing willing winches who
could possibly hate that then suddenly
it's like the movie gets bored and goes
full-on science fiction the second half
of the movie is about an evil
organization led by a guy dressed in
black robes that wouldn't look out of
place in Knights of the Old Republic
evil minions who wear knockoff Darth
Vader masks and laser battles spoiler
alert
turns out that your has actually been
living on a post-apocalyptic sci-fi
earth with Dinosaurs which is pretty
much every eight-year-olds dream this
wasn't even just a case of the screen
right
mashing stuff together it's actually
based off an argentinian comic book of
the same name which was evidently
popular enough to bring to the big
screen it's really not that bad an idea
for a movie but your deserves better
Starchaser The Legend of Oran it's the
story of a young miner who discovers a
magic sword and embarks on an epic quest
to destroy an evil space empire with the
help of robot sidekicks and a rogue
criminal and it's not Star Wars despite
being an animated film star chaser The
Legend of Oran is way less kid-friendly
than Star Wars the characters swear a
lot more and the violence is even worse
and there's the fin BOTS the heroes pick
up an oddly curvy totally not c-3po lady
droid during their adventures like c-3po
she's pretty annoying so how do our
heroes deal with it they stick probes
into her robot but to reprogram her into
a full-on sex bot despite a terrifying
view into the filmmakers fantasies
Starchaser was pretty groundbreaking it
was one of the first 3d animated movies
and one of the first to combine computer
graphics with traditional hand-drawn
animation thankfully those technologies
were also used to make movies that
weren't creepy Star Wars ripoffs space
mutiny in 1978 Glenn Larson managed to
get Battlestar Galactica off the ground
after years of shopping it around
because of the success of Star Wars some
might call it a total ripoff but it
found plenty of success in its own right
enough success that a South African
production company wanted to cash in on
it ten years later the result was space
mutiny without the money for special
effects the production just decided to
go the easy route and steal effect shots
from Galactica use whatever office
equipment they had around and filmed the
thing in brick buildings which were
supposed to represent areas of a
spaceship the story revolves around a
mutiny on a colony ship but the plot is
skeletal at best characters died only to
reappear in the next scene plot elements
appear out of order and it feels like
key pieces of dialogue were cut that
doesn't mean the movie is without charms
it has an awesome go-kart chase through
the engine room of the ship a cool
hula-hoop dance club and be movie icon
Cameron Mitchell hanging around in a
bathroom the strangest element of the
whole fiasco is that by 1988 ripoffs
just weren't profitable anymore and the
movie has too much stolen footage to
stand on its own how they never got sued
remains a space mystery battle beyond
the stars shaka tour Roger Corman threw
his hat into the star wars ripoff ring
with his 1980 film battle beyond the
stars for those who aren't familiar with
Corman's body of work the dude was well
known for making fast cheap movies to
capitalize on whatever craze was going
on at the time he knew how to stretch a
budget and made the most semi-competent
movies he could and battle beyond the
stars was his most expensive to date
coming in at 2 million the film ended up
being surprisingly competent it looked
and felt just like Star Wars but was
more of a loose remake of Seven Samurai
in space most importantly the plot
actually kind of makes sense shockingly
it also has some future big names
attached James Cameron was in charge of
special effects in art direction James
Horner wrote the score and liked it so
much that he basically ripped off
himself and reused it for Wrath of Khan
[Music]
all of that made battle beyond the stars
the most skillfully made ripoff from the
era even better Corman being The
Cheapskate he was didn't break down the
sets after filming and just reuse them
for yet another Star Wars ripoff space
Raiders that guy knew how to get the
biggest bang for his buck the black hole
story wise Disney's legendarily
expensive the black hole actually has
more in common with Star Trek than Star
Wars but with bumbling robot sidekicks
spaceships that look like Mos Eisley
spaceport rejects and costumes that look
like they're fresh out of Darth Vader
supply closet the Star Wars connection
is undeniable what makes this movie so
bizarre is that it gets incredibly dark
robot villain Maximilian is a
frightening cross between Darth Vader
and a Cylon biblical allusions and
gruesome murder lurk around every plot
point humans get melded with robots and
of course we can't forget about the
final scene in which the characters are
sucked into the black hole only to find
the most convincing interpretation of
Hell ever set to film
sleep well Mouseketeer
[Music]
there's arguably a good movie in the
middle of the black hole but Disney
couldn't decide whether to make it child
appropriate or something more heady like
2001 a Space Odyssey Disney would have
to wait a few decades to make actual
Star Wars films amazingly the studio is
also started working on remaking the
black hole no word yet on whether Satan
will make an appearance this time thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]